and I was thinking that my sort of
ability or knowledge of any particular
language is kind of like an iceberg
uh and how is that well because with an
iceberg what you see is a small part of
the iceberg
and what you don't see is a much much
larger part of the iceberg and what I'm
able to say in a lot of my languages is
really a very small part of my total
exposure experience knowledge of that
language so I'm able to use a small
percentage of my vocabulary I might have
a larger area of passive vocabulary and
then beneath that is an even larger
amount of words that I have been exposed
to I may not even have them as passive
vocabulary and I certainly can't use
them and that's the sort of parable of
the iceberg and my language knowledge
thank you bye